Where I grew up in the South, there was a right way to do things and a wrong way to
do things.
And the right way was to do what your family and society thought you should do.
And the wrong way was to do something different.
By age 30, I'd done most everything I was supposed to do.
I'd overachieved in high school.
I attended a prestigious college in the South.
I had a good job, and I'd married well within the childbearing age.
We'd married at my insistence, of course, but neither one of us was fully on board.
So except for moving up north to Boston, which caused my family to collectively take to their
beds, I was on track with what we thought my life should look like, but I wasn't happy,
and I thought it was my career.
In my family, I was expected to go into business.
I'd been in public relations for seven years, but I didn't like the work anymore.
I mean, I was good at it, but I was tired of working with clients, and plus I was working
with companies like retail banking, traffic reporting, hazardous waste recycling, nothing
that really blew my skirt up.
So I quit my full-time job, and I started consulting, and I started taking classes to
figure out what else I could do for a living.
Now, the only criterion for the classes was that the instructors and students could not
know or care what the Financial Times was.
I took needlepoint, directing, French.
I found this brochure for the School of the Museum of Fine Arts in Boston, and I thought,
oh, well, this looks interesting.
And I went to the school, and I talked to the continuing education director, and I asked
him which class he thought I should take, and he said, you need to take art as process.
We take burnout executives in that class all the time.
I sign up.
It's my first day of art school.
I do my best to look artsy, to fit in, but even though I am not wearing pearls, they
are still emblazoned on my chest.
And our instructor, Rhoda, introduces herself, and she says, there is no right way to make
art, and there is no wrong way to make art.
Now this makes me extremely nervous, because I have been raised that there is a right way
and a wrong way to do most everything.
And then she says, the class will focus on process, the process of art making, not the
end result.
Now this makes me even more nervous, because I have been raised to focus on results, and
not just any results, but the best results.
And there are no grades.
Things careen out of control.
If there are no grades, how will I know if I'm overachieving?
I need to know that I'm overachieving.
We start with the basics, and in my entire life, I have never held a stick of charcoal
in my hand, and it feels good.
And I survive the first week of simple art exercises, and I enjoy myself.
And the next week, Bob, one of the three instructors, says, today we're going to do gesture drawings,
very fast drawings, about 45 second poses, and we're going to draw the energy and the
movement and the essence of the figure.
And I am thinking, what the heck is essence, and how the heck do you draw it?
And a man, the artist's model, starts to undress.
And I say, well that's okay, you've seen a naked man before, you've even had sex with
a naked man before.
Your problem is, you don't know how to draw this naked man's essence.
And everybody else apparently does know how to draw his essence, as they're all busily
getting out their easels and knowingly getting out sheets of paper and charcoal and other
drawing mediums with which they excel.
And I'm just standing there like the proverbial deer in headlights, and I begin to watch and
imitate because I am clueless but competitive.
And so I ask Judy, who is standing next to me and also a mature student, I say, Judy,
what are these supposed to look like?
Because of course I think there's only one right way to do this, and we're all going
to draw the same image.
And she looks at me bewildered and says, they're all going to look different.
I'm paralyzed.
What is mine supposed to look like?
Can't I just do a slide presentation for your board of directors, maybe conduct a communications
audit, assess your customer service capabilities?
These are things I know how to do, things in which I excel, and I like to excel, and
there is no way I'm going to excel drawing this naked man's essence.
And I'm about to cry, and then the competitive side of me kicks in and says, well just snap
out of it, you big wimp, and do something.
So I start making these hopeless stick figures every 45 seconds, because that's how fast
the poses are every 45 seconds, and every 45 seconds I feel like a total failure, which
is a lot of times in one hour, it's 80.
And the shame is enormous, and I'm mortified at how inept I am, and I'm beating myself
up for ever trying anything different, for even attempting anything new, and I'm in literal
physical pain, I am so far out of my comfort level, I mean I actually hurt.
And I'm about to cry again, and that's when Bob comes over and shows me what amazing teachers
can do, I don't even know what he says, all I know is he talks me off the ledge and breaks
the vice grip that has a hold of me, and I start to draw.
At the end of class, Bob picks one of my gesture drawings to put up on the wall with a bunch
of other student drawings so we can discuss them.
No one laughs at me or my drawing, it actually holds its own.
I have drawn a naked man, and I feel like I can do anything, but things at home start
to get a little tricky.
My husband is an art director, one of the reasons why I married him, I loved being with
somebody artsy, he seemed so exotic and interesting.
He was the creative one, and I was the business one.
But when I started going to art school, all the roles were off, the balance of power completely
out of sync.
So class continues for the next six weeks, and it's an emotional rollercoaster, I mean
my thinking is shifting and breaking apart and I cry every day.
And my final assignment is a wall installation, which is a term I didn't even know existed
six weeks before.
And it includes these three wall sculptures, these sculptures made out of the New York
Times business sections and the Wall Street Journal, all painted black.
And they're bound in these really tight boxes.
And each piece gets progressively more undone until the final piece explodes.
And Bob, the instructor that talked to me off the ledge, sees it, and he says, Trisha,
you know, you really ought to apply to the museum school.
Well, this thought had never occurred to me before, I mean, in the back of my mind, I'm
going to end up in business school, that this is a once in a lifetime event until I go back
to my normal life, and I'm highly suspicious, and then it occurs to me what's happening.
He's hitting on me.
I have no artistic talent at all.
He's just flattering me until he can get lucky.
And this theory sticks until I find out he's been in a committed relationship for the past
18 years with his boyfriend.
So then I start thinking of other reasons why they may want me to apply.
Maybe they think I have a lot of money and I'll be a big donor, because I was working
at Harvard Business School at the time, or maybe they think I know people who will be
big donors.
And so while I'm using all of my creative energy trying to imagine why I'm not creative,
Charles, one of the instructors, comes up to me and says, Trisha, you really ought to
apply to the museum school.
I mean, you know you're an artist.
You're one of us.
Panic begins to set in.
And I enroll in art school as a part-time student, but I'm still consulting.
And I'm both excited and traumatized, because for the first time in my life, I am not following
the rules.
And I say to my dear friend Sarah, who's also a Southerner, I say, Sarah, I am so afraid
of being different than everybody else.
And she says, oh, Trisha, I'm so afraid of being just like everybody else.
And my marriage begins to explode.
And part of the reason is I'm not supposed to excel beyond men, definitely not beyond
my husband.
I had places I wanted to go, and he just wasn't moving fast enough.
I kept pushing him to move faster so I could move forward.
And one day, he just says to me, Trisha, you just want me to go places I don't want to
go.
At art school, since we don't have grades, we have review boards.
And at the end of each semester, we put up all the work we've done, and two instructors
and several students review the work, give us feedback, and guide us on our creative
path.
And I'm driving to my review board in the Jeep I've purchased for the yet-to-be-conceived
children I assume I'll have.
But instead, it's piled high with artwork.
And at my review board, one of the students writes this on his review board sheet.
You seem to be a little frantic.
Very perceptive.
It has something to do with control.
It's okay to let go.
You're expecting this to be black or white, but the process won't allow that.
You've got to let go.
I'm not sure if he's talking about my artwork or my marriage.
My husband and I separate, and a dear friend of mine says, you know, Trisha, I love my
husband and I love my children, but I never thought I had options.
You have options.
And she's right, because even though my life is blowing apart, or maybe because it is,
I begin to really find my voice and step into my artwork.
My mother sees it and says, why is it so dark?
Why aren't there any heads?
It's getting harder and harder to do my consulting work, and even though I'm getting paid a firehose
of cash, I know that if I do this work for much longer, I'm going to die.
Slowly, but I'm going to die.
And I realize I'm not just in the wrong job or the wrong marriage.
I'm in the wrong life.
I don't want to do what other people want me to do or think I should do anymore.
All I want is to make art.
I'm an artist.
And the week we separate, they tear down my family home of 25 years and my Jeep gets stolen.
I have this keychain with three keys on it, one to the house I don't live in anymore,
one to my family home that's been torn down, and one to my Jeep that's been stolen.
God is banging on my hood.
So I toss the keys, head to art school, and join my tribe.